la chose la plus importante dans la vie soit toujours
les gens là en ce moment c'est
ce qui est vrai bonjour ne le veux pas à Ralph
tu ne me connais pas tu es sur le point de tu l'as
fait sous Horne Shaw c'est un
grand méchant frère c'est un  assassin des forces spéciales
ils ont créé un monstre on
dirait que les péchés de Londres
nous ont suivis à la maison nous sommes chassés
Shaw vit dans un monde qui ne respecte
pas vos règles, que vous le vouliez ou non, vous et
vos amis en faites partie maintenant je
je n'ai pas d'amis je les ai
cette fois il ne s'agit pas seulement d'être rapide
est-ce que quelqu'un peut juste me guider
sera censé faire
ton roman tu as besoin d'air frais juste
besoin de penser que ça s'améliore hein
tout le monde des
mercenaires après assez d'armes
anéantir de petits pays, ici, c'est
fou à un tout autre niveau
quel est le plan DOM une belle balade
non je ne regarde pas
quoi de neuf maintenant quoi de neuf maintenant quoi de neuf
maintenant